i used ai to beat famous architects at
their very own designs in less than 30
seconds i was able to produce amazing
pieces of art similar to that of frank
gehry or even bjark ingles if you stick
around to the end i'm going to show you
exactly how you can get unlimited ai
access completely free of charge today
we're going to break down how this
software works compare my results using
the ai system analyze the pros and cons
of this software and of course show you
exactly how you can get this software
unlimited 100 free of charge first of
all let's start off with the how i use a
series of ai tools also known as
artificial intelligence that basically
reverse engineers google software to be
able to generate an image simply
produced from text now there are many
versions of this available on the
internet some are free some are paid
some are limited access and others are
by invitation only basically once you
find a good one online all you have to
do is type in a series of words that you
want to describe this picture and the ai
will automatically generate a
never-before-seen one-of-a-kind image
for the purposes of this video i used a
discord group chat with an ai bot built
into it called mid journey now there is
a link down below it is not sponsored in
any way shape or form basically mid
journey allows you to generate 25
creative images and after that it asks
you to subscribe to its platform to be
able to test this ai software and its
abilities i compared it to some of the
best architects in the world some of
these architects included frank gehry
frank lloyd wright bjark ingles peter
zunthor oscar niemeyer and of course
zaha hadid each one of these architects
has their own unique style which allows
us to be able to compare it like for
like against the ai first of all frank
gehry is known for his abstract forms
curves and instantly recognizable
designs
he is a one-of-a-kind architect so when
you ask the ai to replicate something
from frank gehry you know it's able to
actually produce his style
and not only was it able to produce one
example it gave me four straight away
and then i used the secondary ai
software to give me another nine
examples straight away this was a great
start to the experiment next we took on
bjr ingles now bjark is a modern-day
architectural visionary he's able to
make powerful forms with little to no
resources his career launched by
developing extremely budget-friendly
projects with exceptional vision and
execution the arc also creates hundreds
of notable designs and therefore the ai
was able to use everything it could to
produce its best work i can see br
king's group creating something very
similar to what this ai was able to
produce so i ran this ai on the discord
chat twice it gave me four different
examples to be able to push that even
further i took it to the next ai that is
again free of charge and it produced
nine more images for that skyscraper
example next on our list is zaha hadid
now everybody knows zaha did or at least
knows of her work so just like the ark
it's no surprise that the ai smashed out
a series of images that can be easily
connected back to zahar's work i asked
it to create a stadium shaped like an
alien spaceship zaha
realistic now the reason i selected
these keywords is that is exactly what
zaha has already produced i wanted to be
able to understand what the ai knew and
what the ai could produce by
automatically replicating these new
words personally i think it did a pretty
good job a little bit more star trek
than zaha did but it still was able to
give me good realistic information that
i could use to then further the creative
journey peter zunthor is a little bit
more unique his work defined a
generation but it didn't really stick to
one particular style you know peter zun
thought when you see it but the ai
wasn't able to recognize that so when it
was told to produce a black circle house
in the snowy mountains peter zundtos
style
it really didn't do the job now look
don't get me wrong this is still really
really good work but at the end of the
day it's not a circle house it's not
really in the peters until style and
it's kind of very mundane last but not
least is oscar nehemiah oscar nehemiah
is personally one of my favorite
architects and i use as inspiration for
my work all of the time so when i asked
the ai to produce a future utopian house
oscar nemai style 8k hyper realistic it
was able to take some of oscar neymar's
work basically extrapolate it and turn
it into the modern day version of a
house which is exactly what i asked for
but very much copy and pasting one
project into another which is basically
plagiarism now if we analyze this ai
from a pros and cons list it gets pretty
simple first of all it is quick it's
easy to use it is great for ideas it can
produce amazing results in any style and
it is forever learning so it's forever
getting better however the ai seems to
latch onto one word the mid-journey
version only lets you use 25
imaginations of your own before it asks
you to subscribe to its paid service if
you're trying to describe multiple ideas
in one image it really starts to
struggle and it also adds up over time
so if you're trying to produce one image
it may take 30 seconds it may take 3
minutes to generate this image but 10
images is half an hour 100 images goes
on for a very very long time i still
don't think this software is 100 ready
for full mass market adoption but it is
getting very very close the invitation
only services like dali e
are phenomenal and that's what takes us
to our very next point i promise that
i'll tell you exactly how you can get
unlimited access to ai 100 free like i
already said mid journey only allows you
25 imaginations and then it asks you to
subscribe
mid journey is actually really really
good because it allows you to upscale
these images it allows you to get high
resolution data of what you're actually
trying to produce
however if you're just experimenting
with the program you can use something
called crayon which is the original dali
e software it's called dali e mini and
it allows you to produce very scaled
down versions of the concepts
unfortunately you cannot scale up you're
basically just screenshotting images so
you're not able to actually blow these
images up and use them for anything but
they're great for idea creation anyway
that's all from me if you enjoyed the
content make sure you check out the
everything architecture playlist on the
side of me here and if you love the
content make sure you smash the
subscribe button down below but like
always i'll see you next monday